Hundreds and thousands of people
are gonna lose their homes. They will die
Let's be honest: for a
cruel and desperate hope
of maximizing profits.
Stop evictions at all costs.
They brought living room furniture
into the streets,
saying this is what
the city will look like
as thousands face eviction.
Their demand: cancel the rent.
A lot of folks have had to choose
whether to eat or to pay rent.
The federal government
and many cities and states
have enacted a series
of temporary measures,
halting residential evictions
in the United States.
Evictions were leading to
unnecessary cases of COVID,
and unnecessary deaths from COVID.
Dubbed "the tenant
movement's giant killer"
by one industry trade magazine,
Cea Weaver is a rising
star in New York politics.
So this is life saving,
and that's the most important thing.
The cancel rent movement,
Weaver told the New York Times
"is also about literally rising
up for real transformation
in the housing market."
In New York, that
transformation is underway,
and it's having a devastating
impact on landlords.
The eviction moratorium isn't
just benefiting the poor;
it's allowing bad actors
to stop paying their rent
without consequence.
Meanwhile, many small landlords
are seeing their life savings disappear,
because they have no choice
but to maintain their buildings at a loss.
One landlord who's been hurt
by the eviction moratorium
is Chao Huai Gao, who
works at a nail salon
and saved for 20 years
to buy a house in Queens.
In March of last year,
a squatter moved in.
This person, who didn't respond
to our interview request,
is a dropout from an
elite private university,
and he has never paid rent.
Because of the eviction moratorium,
there's no legal mechanism
through which Gao can retake
possession of his property.
Meanwhile, his bills are mounting.
He no pay rent, I so angry.
Is a robbery.
So, in my story one landlord says,
This is really a straightforward
issue, it's "robbery."
He's paying heat taxes and a mortgage,
and someone else is living rent-free
and he has absolutely no recourse.
Do you agree with that
characterization? Is this robbery?
No, I don't think it's robbery
and we're also not saying
that the landlord can
never collect the rent-
that's not what an
eviction moratorium does.
It's simply a pause.
So, no I don't agree with it,
I think it's deeply misleading.
But practically speaking,
this landlord will be very lucky,
I mean, just the way housing court runs,
if he is able to collect back rent
in terms of the cost of hiring lawyers,
the delays that come in housing court.
You don't have to be in the
business of being a landlord.
Those are part of the
costs of being a landlord.
That should be understood as
part of the deal, and it is.
But owners say having
almost no legal recourse
when their tenants don't pay their rent
is not something they considered
to be part of the deal
when investing in real estate.
Landlord groups around
the country have sued
on the grounds that halting
the judicial process
that allows them to retake their property
violates their due process rights,
and that the national moratorium
is an unconstitutional
expansion of federal power.
Gao is part of an association
of about 200 Chinese immigrant landlords,
with tenants who have stopped paying rent.
This landlord worked as
a housekeeper at a hotel
that recently closed down.
She says her tenants stopped
paying rent over the summer,
and is demanding a $12,000
cash payment to move out.
I think it's really critical
that mom-and-pop landlords
are prioritized for aid right now.
At the same time, everyone
has taken a haircut,
they don't have a God-given
right to collect rent
just like hotels don't
have a God-given right
to profit off of the tourism industry,
and bars and restaurants
don't have a God-given right
to serve people dinner and wine.
What do we want?
Cancel our rent.
When do we want it?
Now.
If we don't get it?
Shut it down.
Weaver said she feels for these landlords,
but tenants are worse off.
And we know as a matter
of statistical fact
that renters are far less
likely to have wealth,
and renters are far less likely
to have anything in saving.
I know that there's some examples,
like the ones that you're raising,
and I feel for that person
and want them to get the resources
that they need from the state.
The media has predicted a huge wave
of evictions in the United States
if the moratoriums are lifted,
and in New York tenant activists
dragged furniture out into the streets
to dramatize the potential impact.
But, in New York, before COVID,
only about one out of 10 eviction filings
ended in a city marshal or sheriff
physically removing a
tenant from a dwelling.
However, because there existed a process
to which landlords could
enforce their contracts
and get tenants who
weren't paying their rent
to come to the negotiating
table or move out,
they had legal recourse.
One problem with the eviction moratorium
is that in practice it's not
only impacting those in need,
it's also allowing tenants
who can afford their rent
to take advantage of their landlords.
Won, who asked that we
only use her last name,
owns a house in Queens and
works as a home health aid
caring for an elderly couple.
Her husband is a waiter at
this restaurant in Chinatown,
though he's barely been able
to work since the pandemic.
She says that her tenant owes her
more than $80,000 in back rent.
Won says that for tenants
who were unemployed
or financially distressed,
she'd be willing to work with them.
Reason wasn't able to reach
her tenants for comment,
so we're not using their
names in the story.
But we did find that the father
who has a criminal record,
is currently employed in
the construction industry.
And while his girlfriend's
mother and children
live in Won's apartment,
he and his girlfriend are
renting a second apartment
in this house in Queens Village,
where they've also stopped paying rent
and owe $12,000 to the
couple that owns the house,
who are also Chinese immigrants.
But it's not only immigrant landlords
who are being taken advantage of.
Sharon Redhead, who's the
owner of a building in Brooklyn
told the New York Daily News
that some of her tenants
who were out of work have
kept up with their rent,
while others with jobs aren't
paying any rent at all.
Clarence Hamer is the
owner of a two-family home
with a tenant who isn't paying rent,
but is subletting rooms at a profit.
The New York Post told the story
of 88-year-old Harlem
landlord David Howson,
suffering from Alzheimer's,
with a tenant who hasn't
paid a dime since 2016.
"We're completely destitute,"
his daughter told The Post.
The idea that there's a handful of renters
who are maybe working and saying like,
"Oh, I have the money and I'm
just not gonna pay right now"-
All of the data is showing
that that's an aberration.
The data that shows people
who are borrowing to pay rent,
the data that shows that
renters 48% of renters
are behind on their housing costs
compared to 6% of property owners
who are behind on their housing costs.
The data is just with us.
Weaver's referring to census data
that doesn't single out landlords,
but that does show that renters
are more financially distressed
than people who own their own homes.
And newspapers have recounted the stories
of many tenants in
crisis such as Diba Gaye,
whose wife recently died of heart disease,
and who lost his job stocking groceries.
"I don't wanna lose my house too,"
he told The Times.
And Halima Abdul-Wahhab, who
says she and her two children
are at risk of homelessness.
"I'm at a job where I
don't make that much,
but I just try to maintain
as much as I can," she said.
"Rent is not the only thing
that has to be paid every month."
But these individuals can be helped
with the type of direct aid
that the government has been providing
since the early days of the pandemic,
through interest free
loan, stimulus checks,
and a substantial increase
in unemployment benefits.
Cities and states have also spent billions
in federal money on rent relief programs.
These programs bring
their own set of problems
and trade-offs, and those
funded by philanthropy
have proven more effective
than government financed ones.
But if tenants are
receiving the aid they need,
owners should still be
able to turn to the courts
if they don't pay their rent.
Weaver says this approach
fails to help populations
that are hard to reach with direct aid,
like undocumented immigrants.
Her organization helped to
draft a proposed state law
under which the government
would cover missing rent,
no matter the recent tenants hadn't paid,
and with strings attached for
landlords to accept the money.
Because we think it'll get the money out
the fastest, right.
The landlords have rent ledgers,
they have operating statements,
they have rent rolls.
But there's another reason Weaver
and her political allies
want to make landlords
dependent on federal subsidies.
Emergency policies
enacted in times of crisis
are prone to becoming permanent,
which some members of
the cancel rent movement
say is the goal.
We need to think about the
role that exclusion and profit,
which are the sort of characteristics
of the private property
market have played,
and think about different
systems and structures
that we could put into place
that would help more people be housed.
Weaver would like to see
the entire real estate industry
restructured in a model
akin to public housing,
but for rich people too.
In public housing, people are
paying 30% of their income.
What I am envisioning is a world
in which the housing is
owned by a collective,
and people are paying 30% of their income
in order to live in their housing.
If your income is zero you pay zero,
if your income is $500,000 a year,
you're paying 30% of that.
And the government is the sort of owner-
or not even the owner.
The government doesn't
have to be the owner
but the government is what's making sure
all of that sort of works in cash flows.
The debt to GDP ratio
right now is the highest
since World War II,
Trump left us with an additional
$7.8 trillion in debt,
and Biden's agenda would add 11 trillion
on top of what we're already spending
over the next 10 years,
so how can the federal
government also afford
to start subsidizing rental housing costs?
The federal government prints money.
The federal government can
provide money for this.
So it's by printing money?
Sure.
Gao, his wife and two daughters
are living in a one-room studio,
unable to move into the building they own.
And they're afraid to contact
the person squatting there
at a fear that there'll
be sued for harassment.
When Gao and other immigrant landlords
decided to come to the United States
to create a better life,
this is not the American dream
they thought they were buying into.